devastating news death loop got delayed
from holiday 2020
to q2 2021 they ask you how you are you
just have to say that you're fine when
you're not really fine but you just
can't get into it because they would
never understand so we're going to use
it as a fun
segue to talk about the ps5 and xbox
series x launch
lineups
hello and welcome once again to
generation next gamespot's weekly show
all about the playstation 5 and xbox
series x
joining me as usual we're two for two is
xbox expert jordan remain
hello and playstation pro to more
hussein
absolutely throbbing with anticipation
for new consoles
so my god i wondered how you could top
gushing
um like i said up front death loop has
been delayed it's been a quiet week all
around on the next gen
news front so death loops delay let's go
let's just get straight into it i think
uh it's been delayed
to q2 next year arcane leon have said
you know it's the adjustment to working
from home that has led to the delay they
want the game to be
as polished as possible uh when it
launches
um and so they've made the tough
decision to push to next year but there
will be an update
soon so i'm obviously quite devastated
uh that was probably the game that i was
most looking forward to
this holiday season um
but you know i'm also of the mindset
that developers
should take as long as they need to to
make the game make sure the game
is in the states that they want it to be
when it launches evan
please insert me a moto quote here about
delayed game
guys what do you think tam um i think it
was pretty app that a game about being
stuck in a groundhog day
like loop getting a delay has made me
feel like i'm stuck in a groundhog day
like loop given
recent events but yeah arcane has made
some of arguably my favorite stealth
games of this generation alongside metal
gear solo 5.
so i am absolutely willing to give them
whatever time
as if i have any say on what happens but
i'm glad they're taking
the time they need to make the game they
want to make and
polish it and get it to where it needs
to be because they make exceptional
games that
really stick with you so do whatever you
need to do
i hope that they give us a little more
kind of to chew on about the games like
trailers maybe some lore stuff
i think i'll take a few screenshots at
this point so yeah do whatever you need
to arcane please
uh jordan would you reckon i'm not as
broken up about this as i was about the
halo
infinite delay i i i do want to play
death loop i'm not as jazzed about it as
the two of you
are i'm interested in it to say the very
least i like the idea of playing as
two black characters in a 1960s inspired
setting and both of them are trapped in
a literal like
circle cycle of violence i think that
idea is cool and i want to see where it
goes but in comparison to the halo
infinite delay which was like the big
seller for series x playstation 5 still
has
a few first party titles tentatively
scheduled for
2020 and so whereas halo infinite kind
of makes the series x's launch lineup a
little bit of a
ah what is it going to look like losing
death loop is like
okay it's a disappointment i guess but
playstation 5
still seems to be in a pretty good place
launched lineup all things considered
well i'm glad you mentioned launch
lineups jordan
what a segue uh because the big feature
this week that we're going to be talking
about is something that i like to call
a dream launch dream dream dream dream
dream dream
yes dream launch it's i introduced it
like it was a game show
but in reality it's just a feature where
using
what we know of the games that are
coming out this holiday season
as well as what we god what we hope what
we dream what we pray
will be coming out this holiday season
we're going to create a dream launch
lineup for both the playstation 5
and xbox series x
let's do the playstation 5 dream launch
lineup
first we've got five categories we have
exclusive console seller gas
games as a service funnel acronym indie
darling
and wild card please evan
insert uh it's always done in
philadelphia clip here
thank you i'm just assuming that he's
done everybody
i hope he doesn't do it i hope he
doesn't do it i really hope he doesn't
do it
wow [ __ ]
[Music]
let's start with ps5 what is the
dream launch exclusive time will come to
you first
i'm gonna pick a game that doesn't have
a release date but has been in
development for
quite a while if rumors are to be
believed um
i'm gonna pick from software
and blue point games is demon souls
remake
wildlife either elden ring or demon
souls remake is coming
out listen i didn't say it's definitely
coming out this year
let me dream i am your giants are
unrealistic
george you and i have gone for the same
one which is more yeah
see this is why this is where i'm gonna
make the point that
your one might be more realistic but
we're here to dream
first of all secondly i feel like you're
one fits better in the second category
console seller i feel like demon souls
is a game that
now stands to be incredibly popular
because of
everyone jumped on at dark souls onwards
so they got on the from software train
after demon souls which was quite hard
to
find play um on the ps3 so i feel like
that game
being out there having a from software
game available at launch
is going to be massive it will be a huge
attraction for people
whereas your game i feel like is a no
given at this point
but works better as a system seller look
in an alternate
reality where we got anything other than
the absolutely gorgeous
cinematic trailer for the demon slayer
demon slayers
demon souls remake i would agree with
you i would think that that would be
awesome but miles morales
is tentatively scheduled for this year
and people are going to want to play it
people are going to want to buy it's
going to be an
awesome exclusive on playstation 5
because of it
but i do agree with tam that it fits in
a better in a different category
so let's put a pin in miles morales not
literally um
i'm going to say my vote here is demon
souls for
console exclusive you're lying to
yourself yes you're lying to yourself i
don't know
because the next i would say the next
category is more
i'm trying oh what's the different word
that exclusive more prestigious
prestigious prestigious
prodigious i would i would consider
this category console seller to be more
important uh jordan you go for miles
morales i picked watch dogs legion just
because
watch dogs legion is like it was hugely
popular when it came out um
on last gen current gen whatever you
want to call it uh
ps4 and xbox one so i feel like it might
have the same selling power
again as a console seller tam you've
picked
dreaming again yeah i'm dreaming again i
picked horizon forbidden west because i
like to dream
however i will say that miles morales
fits here better purely because
everyone knows horizon's a good game and
eloy everyone loves her
um but if you put a loi and tall neck
robot
thing next to each other what did you
call me uh you know you heard i've
called you
before and i will call you again um
stack them to next to miles morales
spider-man
and ask someone which one of these two
makes you more want to buy
a console um it's it's spider-man
every single time so i feel like as a
console seller
miles morales works better i i will i
will i will settle
for that i i will say though i don't
agree with your
opinion stamp but i would love to live
in your reality where we're getting
demon souls and verizon dreams for
playstation 5.
all right let's move on to gas games as
a service
gas gas
i picked warzone so for context we don't
know
anything like i assume there's a new
card this year
they are teasing the crap out of stuff
sending people packages we're recording
this before anything has been announced
meanwhile
so we know that that game is you know
they've talked about it in the past they
want to support it ongoing
it also makes a hilarious amount of
money um
cod and playstation have a lot like
they've got it they've got a
sweet little relationship going i think
there'll be a lot of pros and benefits
to playing it
on ps5 um tam what's your selection
uh activision also or bungie
specifically
broken up friendship friendship ended
with activision
i am my own best friend now uh bungie
bungie has a pretty good relationship
with
uh in terms of content with playstation
as well and i feel like destiny 2 could
be a great one for them it's already
you know at least the the games the gas
game that has got the most
mind share um so and i imagine
like at a time when there's a decent
amount of games but not a lot of
amazing like immediately known
quantities out there
a destiny would be super appealing
especially if they launch with the
promised you know upgrade path
and the uh the next-gen updates and
bells and whistles uh i think a lot of
people who may have
missed out on jumping on the destiny
train up until this point may be a
little more enticed to get on board with
it now that
bungie has created like a a new entry
point for them
thanks to the new generation of consoles
so my vote goes to destiny 2.
as i originally the cheeky part of my
brain was like
what if what if anthem 2.0 comes out for
next-gen consoles but i i have to agree
with tam it's got to be
destiny two for playstation five i i'm
sorry lucy why would you pick
the second best battle royale when you
could pick
the best first person loot shooter on
consoles it's gotta be destiny too
oh just cause i've missed the boat with
destiny too
and i i just i just like warzone because
it's got so many british people
like stuck enough mucking about love it
all right
let's move on to indie darlings you have
to say it like that yeah that mean
that's the law
um i picked maquette
which is a really interesting looking
game uh
very much up my street it's basically
like russian nesting dolls
that's how the level is set up where
it's like a smaller version of the level
is within
each level and so you can take things
from like a bigger version of the level
and use it to solve puzzles in the
smaller version vice versa i think
changes you make in one version
will be made in the bigger version on
the smaller version it's really cool
it reminded me a lot of you know
stacking
it has a really cute art style too um
and it's just very much up my street
i'm very excited about it um so i picked
my cat
jordan i knew the distant light it's a
small little game that doesn't have too
much traction but it reminds me of
hollow knight it's a bit more of a
shooter than a hack and slash and
i just i just want a new metroidvania to
play on a next-gen console that's all i
really want
but i think thinking about it tam's
choice is probably going to be the one
that we go with
just because it has the most hype behind
it because it has the catchiest jingle
i of course have picked drug snacks
because it is the game that has the most
like
hype behind it right now right now it is
the indeed darling
of of modern gaming right now so i
understand it's like an
acid trip to see every single trailer
for this game what do people see in this
it's
it's the potential that it holds and as
we have already established
jordan you're very bad at dreaming big
um but drugs saying that for the wild
card
for wildcard snacks
it just makes a lot of sense because one
like you know people are taking snapchat
filters
no snapchat instagram filters of
themselves posting it endlessly
and you know the the the uh kero kero
bonito song is like
getting played non-stop and everyone's
just talking about drug snacks so i feel
like it's a
a very safe bet to say like that's a
that's a dream scenario to have
drug snacks available day one well
it's weird because we kind of used wild
card for exclusive
um but this is this is a true wild card
you know all the
the the games that we used in exclusive
like we know are coming at some point
wild card means you can pick any
defunct franchise any whisper
any rumor and that's your pick so
i've picked overwatch too
because god i just i know blizzcon's
been canceled this year
but they're also not making any heroes
for current overwatch
and kind of play a lot of overwatch
i totally forgot that game's even coming
out what are they doing
but no like if if that that would be my
wild card prediction that it's like it's
getting it just gets
dropped like holiday this year i would
absolutely love it and
oh yes please but tam what's what's your
wild card prediction
you know what my world calculation is
there is baby it's bloodborne it's back
for episode two
i will take i will say jordan's jordan's
pick is actually probably what uh
i'm super excited about but in my heart
if they just put out a little
little abe patch for me i'd be very
happy just improve the loading times
maybe stabilize the frame rate in some
areas and you just make
the the perfect version of bloodborne
that's what perfect version of the
perfect
and bloodborne who could have possibly
predicted that you two would take
this
what's your pick so stick with me on
this
mass effect updated graphics maybe
update the combat system because it's a
little old at this point
mass effect 2 mass effect 3 love it
and andromeda no god
no god please no no
no no yeah they had us the first half
i'm not gonna lie
you should have stopped there trilogy
all four games
next gen graphics updated combat on the
old games
i would oh my god
i would lose it i would yeah that's
it i mean for context for me i
never finished andromeda it didn't grab
me as much i think i think it's because
i wanted it too much to be like the
original trilogy and i maybe didn't give
it its fair
shake but if it were to come to a new
console looking all shiny and new bugs
fixed
you would try it you wouldn't i would
try it but i would 100 do a trilogy run
first oh yeah you had to do it in order
but like that would be awesome just a
great surprise launch like oh yeah
playstation 5's out today and uh
you can play all four mass effect games
on it here you have
the next generation of rider looking
like he's gonna murder you
while in your sleep fixed most of the
bugs
tam you have to let the launch version
of that i i
i took i took time out of work to play
that
he did it was your job no i took a day
off which you
you realize how rare that is for me to
do take a day off dedicated to a game
i was like so our dream launch lineup
for ps5
before before hands a thrown and
social distancing is broken uh for ps5
we've got demon souls mars morales
destiny 2 drug snacks bug snacks
goddammit and mass effect quadrilogy
like
okay dreams can come true dreams
dreams if all those games were available
on playstation 5
at launch two baby a triple
a quintuplet a ps
all right let's talk about xbox series x
uh and do the same in those categories
so first category
exclusive jordan you and i have picked
the same one
um again because great minds uh the
medium by blue
team it just looks really cool i'm
giving mad like
control but more supernatural vibes off
of it i don't want to play it so bad
yeah me too where's tam again
i'm out here dreaming i'm dreaming call
me morpheus call me to morpheus
i am the dreamweaver
i have picked i have
picked fable the worst kept secret in uk
video game development if at any point
over the last 10 years or five years or
whatever it may be
you had a uk address you probably
received a
crumpled up piece of paper through the
mail that says new fables in development
i was playground i would yeah i was
talking to my granddad once and he was
like son
you're an abject failure and also did
you know that
fables coming back and i was like yes
granddad i did
both of those i knew those um but yeah
fable has been
in development at playground for an
extended period of time
we've only seen a cg trailer for it and
i feel like that in my heart is because
microsoft is just pacing themselves
they're spacing the beats out
and dreaming right now or maybe it's not
even close to being done tim
dreaming close to being done i don't
understand why you don't let me dream
uh if i'm dreaming if they came out and
went
all right fable was gonna be there day
one that would be incredible
that would be incredible you know what
i'm gonna allow it
i don't think we're allowing him to
dream like this because we've got
nothing else going on jordan we need to
dream
and also i'm british so it's i'm
contractually obligated to
say fable support the other brit
let's move on to console seller i
picked cyberpunk i know
obviously it was a third party title
that was my really
really terrible uh keanu reeves
impression that was keanu reese after
seven packs of cigarettes
cyberpunk i can't do it um i'm british
anyway i picked cyberpunk because
although it's
it's multi-platform i feel like because
xbox have
like the marketing tie-in you know you
can get the cyberpunk xbox one and all
the controllers and stuff i feel like
maybe
some people's minds will be like oh yeah
i want to play
series x so that would that would be a
dream
for me but uh time what do you got i was
originally gonna go for
assassin's creed valhalla because one
assassin's creed traditionally does
really well
especially when they're in the launch
window we've had that happen a few times
and they're also supporting the consoles
um
uh from the outset instead of coming up
with a patch that will be delivered
later on down the line like cyberpunk is
however like
uh in the darling drug snacks it is very
much
cyberpunk is very much in the zeitgeist
right now there's few games out there
that have as much
hype pushing it forward as that game so
i feel like for a lot of people
that might be enough to be a console
seller like you want to play the next
game from cd projekt red
critically acclaimed studio massively
ambitious game get the console that's
supposed to be super powerful
get that game and you're sorted i feel
like that's an that's a
good compelling system seller um uh
proposition there jordan yeah i was
originally gonna go with crossfire x
because i'm like well halo infinite's
delayed so maybe microsoft can kind of
promote this game as their story based
first person
shooter but tam you're right like
cyberpunk is the game that has all the
hype this year and
to lucy's point if xbox came out and
they were like oh yeah
cyberpunk 2077 looks best on series x
that could that could probably move a
system or two i could sway a few people
let's talk about games gasps sorry i
almost i almost mispronounced it let's
talk about gas let's talk about games as
a service
um i've actually played crossfire x for
this although i kind of feel like a
fraud in doing so because the thing that
has got me excited about crossfire x is
the single player campaign
which remedy you're making i'm not
really interested in the multiplayer but
it could be really interesting i'm
interested to see where it goes with it
like it has a huge fan base
it's been well known for years i'm
interested to see what a brand new one
looks like
tam what you got i think it's ironic
that for once microsoft's butt prevented
the release of toxic gas
that was a just a a simpsons reference
just shoehorned in there
because i hope i hope you enjoy it
and i think it's ironic that once dad's
butt prevented the release of toxic gas
i was gonna i was gonna go with sea of
thieves um it's come a long way
it's uh it's a much different game of
course i cannot play it because the
gentle sway of the sea makes me sick
um but uh land lover
makes me sick too yeah i'm very
landlocked
uh but there's a lot to already play
within that game and i think it's
included as part of game pass as well um
if they like upgraded it a bit
and did like a promotional kind of
campaign around it again to be like hey
this amazing pirate game out that you
can play
um with all your pals and also it's
available for free if you subscribe here
i feel like that's that's
a pretty good spot to be in jordan
yeah easy peasy master chief collection
if halo infinite's not going to be there
at launch
just promote the hell out of the four
five six halo games that you have on
sirius x at launch then
uh i can't think of any better game for
our games as a service for xbox
yeah i am inclined to agree i think
master chief collection
is is that uh games as a service though
is it it's kind of i guess you could
but they're adding weapon skins to it
now so it's like you can get
challenges and things i'm gonna you know
what
jordan i'm gonna allow you to dream
because i am that kind of person that is
not a dream it is a game
we know what we play upon series x
let's move on to indie darlings i don't
know why i
go i like it my voice gets very joanna
lumley i'm into thank you
i've picked 12 minutes uh annapurna
everything they touch
turns to gold and it's usually something
that's my
um i'm really intrigued by 12 minutes i
love the kind of groundhog day
feeling vibes you know the vibes
you're on the pipes tom what about you
oh i have picked after uh drug snacks as
indie darling there's one game that
sticks out to me and it is of course
the gunk um i think we all need the
answer to
the question what are you going to do
with all that gunk or that gunk inside
your trunk
disgusting i think i think this is it
yeah they can't get sucked up into some
sort of vacuum like luigi's mentioned
stuff
but i feel like yeah that's that's
that's a game that has also gathered a
lot of steam and it looks really
interesting it looks really cool
i think i'm right in saying it's from
the steamworld team
um which has a great history of
producing really good games really
interesting games um
if i'm wrong jordan please do the big
family family feud style
the gunk looks really cool i'm excited
to check that out and i feel like it
stands out in a
in a way and also has a lot of backing
and momentum behind it
it's like isn't that a small dream that
you have there isn't that game scheduled
for 2021 oh now you want to criticize my
small dreams i can't dream big
the country is a smaller dream let's go
children what's your pick
i'm going for the veil a game that is
tentatively scheduled for
xbox for 2020 game where you play as a
woman who's blind but it's the same like
whole
rpg stick where you're kind of like
traveling from town to town
and shopping and interacting with people
and choosing dialogue options
you just can't actually see anything
which is cool which is fascinating i
i don't think it's going to do that well
on xbox i don't know how you advertise a
game that's in
pretty much a black screen the entire
time but if xbox can figure out a way to
do that and if they promote it
it would be awesome but just thinking
about it 12 minutes is probably the
safer option because xbox has been
promoting that for
years now and everyone kind of seems a
little bit excited for it
and like you said lucy anna perna just
doesn't miss
like they haven't produced a bad game
yet
i think i'm willing to give it to 12
minutes as well purely because
they use the carpet from the overlook
hotel in the trailer so
gotta support the shining fans yep all
right and finally
wildcard i kind of did a high school
musical wildcats thing there i'm very
sorry
um i inspired by jordan
have picked mass effect quadrilogy just
because i'm trying this like
law of attraction uh what is it
visualize what you want and put it out
into the world and
chaos magic this this this is our years
finally the year that we get
those hd remakes of mass effect oh
man i just i would
say man no i wouldn't i wouldn't care
man
i would i don't know what i'd do come
back to me with that but i would i would
absolutely adore
just to revisit those games again but i
i
did play through mass effect 2 um a few
months ago and i was like
god if this was you know shining a
graphics and like little tweaks to the
gameplay a lot of tweaks to gameplay
from aspect one but
i would love to experience that story
again so that's that's my pick for a
wild card
i can dream please
yay you can dream for wildcard i don't
care about dreams here
this is the dream lounge tam what about
you
i'm gonna i'm gonna do something
controversial and i'm gonna improve upon
your suggestion there
and i'm gonna do the mass effect trilogy
why do you what we do we need to deny
that what we do
it's a decent game what we do is we take
three of the greatest
rpgs ever created put them in one
package
drop the dead weight and then just put
that out there this
perfect thing why are you making the
deal worse you are
taking away a game you can't it's gonna
get reviewed and then people are gonna
go
we've got three of the best mass effect
games of all time
better than ever they also put in
andromeda for some reason we're gonna
have to give it a tour and maybe people
would like play it again and be like you
know what we gave it a really negative
you know what
pb still sucks you know what i walked
into this room and there's seven krogans
looking at each other i'm sorry that pb
isn't as good as liara andromeda wasn't
going to be
as good as the first trilogy and she
wasn't even close
i'm getting it hey boys
i'm gonna like like a cat like spray you
with some water bottles
to get you to back off look
like what you like tam i'm gonna veto
that because it's called trilogy get
another game it's fine
jordan wants your pick for wild card all
right this one is for you alessandro
it's gotta be hollow knight
silk song which is only technically
confirmed for pc and switch i know
but imagine if series x came out on day
one they're like oh and by the way
there's a next-gen version of this game
on xbox i would lose my
i love hollow knight so much and i've
been waiting for silk song
all year team cherry has said it's
definitely coming in 2020 2020 is
halfway over
and i need something good to feel
something in this
crappy crappy year i haven't i haven't
loved anything so far
give me hollow knight give me another
holiday may i suggest
i guess i could play bloodborne again oh
yeah
i think but new hollow knight new hollow
knight
we know that we i mean i'm not i'm not
crushing your dreams here
i will i will it sounds like you're
about to and you're i want to go
because i can't get into holland i suck
i'll get behind mass effect i can get
behind mass effect
i but i i also you know what i support
your dreams jordan
um but ultimately i also support mass
effect so
that's fine mass effect is fine i want
to be a
trilogy again before
time comes up with the river talk so
let's go through our our final picks
so series x we've got
fable cyberpunk 2077 the master chief
collection
12 minutes and the mass effect
quadrilogy like
i don't even want to rate between the
two between like ps5 and xox series x i
just think
we're all the winners if that lineup
happened but it was a dream thing that
we came up with so probably one
one wins everyone wins no i think it was
that was just a fun thing to just like
remember
some of the games that are coming out
later this year revisit some of the
games that are already out but we get to
play on new consoles um please let us
know what you think of our dream launch
lineups in the comments below
and please come up with your own um
we'll be in the comments
and judging them appropriately but also
like it's fun especially for indie
darling to go through games that were
announced
and like i've just forgotten about but
now when i was researching this i was
like making notes about stuff i want to
play later this year so
i encourage you all to do the same thank
you so much for joining us on this
second episode
of generation next we will of course be
back again next friday youtube.com
gamespot in the meantime tam where can
people find you
you can find me in a dark corner
boleteria getting high on drug snacks
and on twitter at tomorrowh
jordan you can find me on twitter at jm
remain where we stand mass effect
andromeda and talk about how pretty it
is
and i'm on twitter at lucy james games
who never finished mass effect andromeda
but i'm considering giving it another go
i don't know why i did that
like weird thing at the end you know
what we're just gonna roll with it
thanks for watching see you next week
[Music]
you